if you are interesting I have specially
prepared it in English this is the list
of strikes it has 33 counts about 300
missiles during this time have been
launched and they attained kahov kadam
so finally but most experts say that
missiles couldn't have caused the damage
most of those Experts of their sitting
back in the rooms and just thinking out
loud what they think about these effects
why would why would this government want
to destroy the dam you were in control
of the dam you have the means to destroy
that yes of course you have the motive
to destroy that damn and you have the
opportunity to destroy that it's a year
ago one of the major generals of Ukraine
has said that they are going to blow up
the dam to prevent a Russian offensive
it has been published in the Washington
Post I'm not sure in December almost
here